some of the lights on the Las Vegas
Strip were dimmed overnight to mark one
week since the mass shooting that killed
58 people and wounded nearly 500 the
first term the first team of officers to
enter pattex hotel suite appeared last
night on 60 minutes
they told correspondent Bill Whitaker
that gunman Stephen paddock apparently
had been preparing for days and no
detail was overlooked bill is here and
we will talk to him in a moment but
first we have part of a 60 minute report
on what the officers saw what do you see
an armory an armory so many guns so many
magazines stacks and stacks of magazines
everywhere just in suitcases all neatly
stacked against pillars that were in the
room all stacked up rifles placed all
throughout all kinds of monitors and
electrical equipment he had in there it
just looked like almost a gun store
shell casings all over the floor I could
smell the Gunpowder that it would have
went off in the room we were tripping
over guns tripping over long guns inside
there were so many that many yes my
initial scan of wouldn't coming in the
room with my rifle it's just seeing I'm
seeing one male down bleeding from the
face he's not a threat kept going kept
going keep going he said one male down
that was the shooter yes Stephen paddock
what were his wounds I didn't see any
apparent wounds to his head but I did
see a lot of blood that had come out of
his mouth well there was a bloody
revolver
I think nearby nearby him that was on
the ground consistent with him shooting
himself what else did you see I saw a
few phones laptops a couple of laptops
he had in there a lot of drills and
drove out of thrills in drill bits all
kinds of tools this was eerie very Airy
and the dust from the explosive breach
and then you got the flashing lights and
it looks straight up like out of a movie
paddock head screwed shut the stairwell
door to his floor to try to keep the
officers from getting to him
the officers had a bar and they pried
the door open when they got in the room
they found a note that he had had
written he had calculated the trajectory
of the bullets and how far the audience
was going to be away from his room so
that he could maximize his accuracy and
his carnage talk about well-planned
more than many questions here how did
they find him well there was a security
guard at the hotel who was responding to
a door ajar alarm and he walked near the
door the shooter had cameras set up and
they believed they saw this security
guard coming in and opened fire 200
rounds shot down the hallway at the
security guard got him in the leg didn't
kill him he survived but that's what
alerted the Las Vegas police that this
is where the shooter was and what a
lucky thing because the security guard
wasn't even going to the shooter as you
point out he just wanted to go the jorah
door but your piece last night number
one bill was so well done and what
fascinated me about it was a picture
that those officers painted they go up
to the floor the fire alarm is going off
there's it's dusty in the room there's
flashing lights and these four officers
had never worked together before so
they're sort of working together on the
fly they were an ad hoc really were
there were two members of the k9 unit
there was Detective from the gang unit
there was one SWAT officer and they
actually found each other at the hotel
in the stairwell going up to the 32nd
floor they formulated a plan and figured
out how to execute this plan and then
went forward from there but they had
never worked together like this it's
amazing feel also that they changed
their preparation after the 2008 Mumbai
attack at the hotel there in India yeah
well sheriff Lombardo told us that
before Mumbai
officers would set up a perimeter and
try to keep everybody away and zero in
on the shooter after Mumbai they decided
that the best way to approach this was
to go after the shooter no matter what
yeah so all of these officers knew that
that was their goal they come together
they don't know each other but you're
from Swat you're a food chain
you're a detective let's get this unit
together get up there and stop this guy
you've done do amazing piece thank you
very much the Whitaker for joining us at
the table